no one has higher hopes than the studio
when it comes to a movies franchise
potential if they sense a feature could
be the start of something major
they might even greenlight a follow up
before the film even hits theaters but
in some cases those sequel plans are
embarrassingly premature here's some
movies that were so bad their sequels
were actually canceled the Mortal
Instruments City of Bones the successes
of Twilight and the hunger games made
adaptations of young adult novels hot in
Hollywood
Sony seemed poised to capitalize by
bringing Cassandra Clare's The Mortal
Instruments City of Bones to the big
screen with plans to follow with the
second installment city of ashes
unfortunately for the studio the film
was a disaster with critics and
audiences earning back just above half
of its production costs instead the
series was adapted to the small screen
as the TV series Shadowhunters Fantastic
Four Fox's 2015 reboot of Fantastic Four
may have seemed like a good idea at the
time especially since it boasted a
quartet of critically favorite actors
and Michael B Jordan miles teller Jamie
Bell and kate mara critics
overwhelmingly hated it however and the
box office results were terrible a
sequel is slated for 2017 but it never
went into production John Carter
Disney's John Carter was such a
box-office bomb that the film's title is
now often used as an adjective to
describe a grossly underperforming
picture the film's critical reception
was moderate at best but would really
destroyed the would-be franchise was how
much of a loss the studio took at the
box office the film reportedly cost a
whopping 250 million dollars to make not
counting its marketing expenses and
earned just 73 million in North America
ouch Green Lantern although Ryan
Reynolds has since proven his worth in
the superhero market by way of Deadpool
his turn as the Green Lantern was a
franchise non-starter and remained
something of a star in his filmography
Green Lantern tanked the box office at
Green Lantern 2 lost its greenlight
Terminator Genisys 2015's terminator
genisys couldn't quite recapture the
fanfare of the original series even with
the reappearance of Arnold
Schwarzenegger as the titular Terminator
as an added boost the movie performed
poorly with critics and domestic
audiences which made the cancellation of
its sequel plans far from surprising The
Cat in the Hat
adaptations of dr. Seuss's books have
usually done well including How the
Grinch Stole Christmas horton hears a
who and Lorax but critics and audiences
rejected the 2003 live-action take on
one of Zeus's most iconic properties The
Cat in the Hat the film scored just 10
percent on Rotten Tomatoes and
financially underperformed as well Sue's
widow Audrey Geisel went so far as to
refuse any further live-action films
Battlefield Earth John Travolta's
unintentionally hilarious costume was
the least of battlfield Earth's problems
this infamous dud which was supposed to
be followed up with a sequel to cover
the rest of l ron hubbard's 1000 page
plus sci-fi epic was laughed off by
reviewers and largely ignored by
audiences Tron Legacy it took more than
two decades for the first sequel to
1982's Tron to come down the pike and it
looks like it might take just as long
for the next one the 2010 movies
domestic box-office was mostly a bust
and despite an animated TV spin-off
Disney abandoned plans for another movie
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos of
the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which scrapped
sequel you'd most love to see someday